and you have a beard in the field listen
yeah yeah I had a beard I got a beard
they gave me the beard you know I think
there's a real it's always tricky
because I know there's a lot of purists
who kind of want you know cap to look a
certain way and but but you know so it's
a try and you know discuss whether or
not we let the look deviate from the
origin you know went through a few
discussions but but it was really nice
that they let that happen and it lends
itself to the arc and to what he's what
he's going through not just a different
look but but uh you know a different
headspace yeah and I am joined now by
superstar writer and director Joe Russo
who is you know known for directing a
lot of the Marvel movies but of course
Captain America Winter Soldier Captain
America Civil War and you're currently
you're literally on set right now
directing Avengers three and four
talking about Captain America either the
two movies I was curious if there was an
idea that you had that you truly loved
you know he was saying in creating stuff
you have to kill your babies obviously
you can't you know deal with a character
called Captain America without you know
dealing with the thematics behind that
and and and you know so we wanted a we
wanted a relevancy to it and and we
wanted to put him in a position where
you know he was questioning the chain of
command and and you know so you'll see
into these Avenger films he's on a very
specific journey as a character
some people have suspected that you know
he may be Nomad heading into Avengers 3
and I wouldn't say that he is exactly
nomad but he is the spirit of that
character every fan has a different
opinion about what they want out of
these movies you know if you try it if
you try to please everybody you're gonna
wind up pleasing no one so really what
we do at the end of the day is tell the
story that we want to see my brother and
I am that we are happy with no matter
what the budget is you just have to be
focused on telling that story that is
really passionate to you and very
emotional hey everybody so we got a
nomad preview for Avengers infinity war
pretty much everybody thought the
Captain America was going to become the
nomad character because of his beer
because of the way he lost the shield it
was just part of that arc of the comic
so just in keeping with what's going on
in the movies even though as the
director Joe Russo was saying that it's
not exactly the same thing as in the
comics because what was happening with
the Nomad character when he debuted was
very different from what was going on
with the Infinity Gauntlet saga with
Thanos so a whole lot of comics during
the 70s there's a lot of 70s stuff
happening during infinity war but mostly
thematically mostly heist movie stuff
because of fan o's quest pretty cool of
him to do an interview like this so I'll
say new round of that Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
just be a subscriber and leave a comment
about marble on the video but related to
infinity war separate from this Captain
America stuff is that brie Larson is
doing Captain Marvel stuff they've been
working on that dome for a while they're
getting ready to roll cameras so they've
been posting all kinds of pictures with
her at Air Force bases getting ready for
her to do those pre sequences before she
heads into outer space before she gets
her powers and it'll be fun to see how
she bumps into Nick Fury because
separately samuel l.jackson did an
interview talking about how there would
be a different looking face for Nick
Fury now he made it sound like there was
going to be a different actor because it
said during the 90s that would have two
eyes but I think what they'll do is
there might be different versions of him
throughout the movie but he himself
samuel l.jackson is in the Captain
Marvel movie we're just gonna see
different versions of him one of them
will be before he lost one of those eyes
suddenly that scene from Winter Soldier
about how he lost his eye is that much
more important
I sent the greatest soldier in history
to make sure that didn't happen
soldiers trust each other that's what
makes it an army not a bunch of guys
running around shooting guns last time I
trusted someone I lost an eye there have
been talks about a Captain Marvel cameo
during infinity war but because of the
way those movies are being filmed in how
their sandwich inge the Captain Marvel
movie in between them it just makes
sense that of course there's going to be
a Captain Marvel post-credits tag with
her character or at least a moment where
somebody references her that leads into
the Captain Marvel movie it provides you
with a sense of continuity as we roll in
to Avengers 4 so it'll seem like one
continuous story even though technically
the purpose of caf
Marvel is really just to be her origin
story it'd be like watching Star Wars
where you see Empire Strikes Back Darth
Vader reveals that he's Luke Skywalker's
father then you jump back to episode 3
watch him become Darth Vader then jump
back to present day in Episode six so
that's kind of what's going on with the
timeline during infinity war Captain
Marvel and then Avengers four it'll be
really cool and for the most part I
don't think that anybody's gonna have
any problems following the timeline but
jumping back to Captain America very
literally he looks like he's being drug
through the mud you look at pictures
like this he definitely looks like he's
the worst for where whatever he's been
off doing between the time he dropped
Bucky off with black panther in when we
pick up an infinity war but what we know
right now is the black widow also went
to ground she's probably been in contact
with him people know where Steve Rogers
has been and they're probably just
leaving him alone because Wakanda aside
iron man wants to find someone they're
gonna get found pretty fast but the
reason why he became Captain America
again in the comics is because he ran
into Hawkeye who at the time was the
golden Archer I know we've all seen
Hawkeye and his Ronin gear here he runs
into Hawkeye Hawkeye gives him the
speech where he's like you can't leave
behind your life of heroism so he
eventually picks the mantle back up
again but literally he gets a call to
action from Iron Man on that cellphone
that he gave him at the end of Civil War
if you didn't watch Rick and Morty
season 3 they very literally did a
parody of that trope where they get a
literal call to action Rick's like I do
not answer literal calls to action a
literal call to adventure Morty let it
go to voicemail Rick the educators only
call when the universe itself is at
stake they're the first line of defense
against evil they're the guardians of
the unguarded or the writers of their
own press releases Morty there are a
bunch of drama queens it's been an hour
talking and 20 minutes jumping around
while [ __ ] blows up they're a phase we
did one it was the big event of that
summer
so hopefully that explanation from the
director clarifies what's going on with
Captain America Nomad in the movie he is
the Nomad character in everything but
name like it's not gonna be exactly like
the comics so they're not gonna walk
around calling him Nomad but it is the
Nomad storyline and that's how they
treat a lot of big comic book storylines
like Scarlet Witch envisions
relationship I should probably do a
video about them soon too because there
have been some casting rumors about
people that might be their children from
the comics so if you're not a big comic
book person short explainer for this
video is is that they had children in
the comics but because later comic book
writers and editors wanted to get rid of
them they're like we need to get rid of
these kids they're not interesting
anymore they turned it into this big big
twist so Scarlet Witch lost her mind
they might be doing a version of that
with their relationship and even though
I think that vision is going to survive
there's gonna be you know big twist
because Thanos does need the mind gem
and you can't really take it out of his
forehead without causing serious damage
so we can just follow up with that in
the Scarlet Witch in vision video
sometime in the next week or two but
leave all your infinity war video
requests in the comments below and like
I said you know new Captain Marvel stuff
has started dropping so by the time
we're watching infinity war in theaters
they'll be dropping official previews
and promos for Captain Marvel they'll do
like an official costume reveal I think
they'll save the official Captain Marvel
trailer for Comic Con this summer
because it's actually not that far away
after you've already seen infinity war
like you have a man and the wasp in June
then you have Comic Con and then you
have a bunch of other people's superhero
movies in the fall so we'll do trailer
update in a little while there'll be a
bunch of trailers coming for the
Superbowl we don't know exactly which
ones yet but like I said there's a new
route of that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway
all you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber leave a comment about Marvel
on the video congratulations to the
winner from my last video Jacob Blaine
please private message me so I can get
your contact details click here for
brand new black panther and click here
for brand new flash thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]